[Musica]
[Applauso]
quante volte avete sentito nell'ultimo
periodo
iamm ormai non si può più dire nulla
una volta ci si faceva una risata adesso
tutti offendersi questo è un errore di
ragionamento pensare che prima non si
offendesse nessuno pensare cioè che se
prima una cosa non si vedeva
e adesso si significa che quella cosa
non c'era realtà c'era eccome c'è sempre
stata e che prima non aveva occasione di
manifestarsi
mi scuso per quello che sto per dire
sarò molto schietta ma solo perché
voglio essere chiara [ __ ] non si
doveva dire neanche negli anni 80 così
come [ __ ] così come [ __ ] se la
sensibilità su alcuni temi aumenta e
perché adesso finalmente si sentono le
voci di quelle persone che sensibili a
quel tema lo sono sempre state una volta
le uniche voci che si sentivano erano
quelle di chi aveva il potere quindi
possiamo dircelo non le donne non le
persone nere non la comunità lgbt
lesbiche gay bisessuali transgender e
altro questo perché era chi aveva il
potere a decidere se e quando accendere
i microfoni quindi le voci che si
sentivano erano sempre le stesse
adesso con internet
ognuno di noi ha un microfono ognuno di
noi può potenzialmente parlare a tutto
il mondo
ecco allora che su twitter va in
tendenza il pensiero di una persona che
non ha potere però ha il potere di dirlo
ecco che diventa virale un video di una
minoranza che dice le cose così non
vanno bene
ecco che un'azienda fa una pubblicità
sessista omofoba razzista e fallisce
perché i milioni di voci che sussurrano
che così non va bene fanno un baccano
enorme se vengono microfonate qualcuno
pensa che per evitare certi scivoloni
sia sufficiente
conoscere le regole del gioco allora è
questa parola non la possiamo più dire
questo stereotipo va smontato un pochino
qui i ragazzi sono tutti maschi ci
mettete una donna una qualsiasi ecco se
non è bianca meglio dai così siamo un po
inclusivi dai ragazzi lo sappiamo come
funziona
eppure ciclicamente c'è qualcuno che ha
potere che conosce queste regole del
gioco che si ritrova comunque ad
offendere una minoranza e se va bene si
scusa senza capire di preciso per cosa
debba scusarsi ma almeno si scusa se va
male gioca la carta del ma non si può
più dire niente cercando di passare per
la vittima
sapete perché accade perché conoscere le
regole del gioco non è sufficiente
perché le regole del gioco sono a loro
volta governate da altre regole
se vogliamo fare un passo avanti
dobbiamo conoscere le tre regole che
stanno alla base delle regole del gioco
regola numero uno se la cosa non
riguarda te in prima persona non fai tu
le regole vale a dire che non è un
bianco a decidere se una cosa è razzista
non è un eterosessuale a decidere se una
cosa è omofoba non è un uomo a decidere
se una cosa è sessista
mi è capitato più di una volta di
sentire alcuni amici miei neri
lamentarsi di cose che per me erano
assolutamente non problematiche hai
visto la campagna di raccolta fondi per
l'africa è così degradante mio cervello
andava in tilt come degradante è una
campagna di raccolta fondi per l'africa
danno i soldi all'africa quella
celebrity che continua a mettere foto su
instagram di lei con i bambini neri nei
villaggi è che la smette scusa
ma come quando è che la smette ma questa
è piena di soldi potrebbe passare la sua
vita in vacanza invece va lì ad aiutare
e tu dici quand'è che la smette è
normale che questa sia la prima reazione
perché ci sembra di sentire qualcosa
fuori testa in realtà lo è è fuori dalla
nostra di testa se siamo bianchi per noi
quelle cose sono positive quindi quando
sentiamo una persona nera lamentarsene è
facile pensare che sia troppo sensibile
addirittura ingrata
questo perché ci dimentichiamo la regola
numero uno la cosa non riguarda noi in
prima persona non facciamo noi le regole
non è un bianco a decidere se una cosa è
razzista perché è difficile riconoscere
il razzismo se non ne sei vittima perché
non sei allenato a vederlo ci ho messo
un po a ma ho iniziato a fidarmi di
questa regola e anziché dire tu sei
matto
ho cominciato a chiedere perché
perché la campagna di raccolta fondi per
l'africa e degradante perché la
celebrity che mette le foto su instagram
di lei con i bambini neri nei villaggi
dovrebbe smetterla la campagna di
raccolta fondi per l'africa è degradante
perché racconta l'africa sempre solo in
un modo cioè come un continente tutto
uguale dove non possono salvarsi da soli
e degradante perché sfrutta il corpo
nero per muovere a compassione una
persona per quei due minuti che servono
per mandare un messaggino e donare un
euro ma non crea alcun cambiamento
culturale non fa progredire l'africa e
di certo non fa progredire noi la
celebrity che mette su instagram le foto
di lei con i bambini neri nei villaggi
la deve smettere perché si sta
atteggiando a salvatrice bianca eccola
guardate questo angelo sceso dal cielo
per aiutare che brava signora mia
potrebbe essere ovunque invece li fa
niente se non abbiamo neanche idea di
dove sia questo li
e soprattutto fa niente se non abbiamo
la minima idea di chi siano i
professionisti locali che devono pur
esserci che si fanno il mazzo
quotidianamente per migliorare la
situazione dall'interno e che
continueranno a farlo anche quando i
riflettori se ne saranno andati perché i
riflettori seguono lei non loro quante
cose a cui non avevo mai pensato
quante donne abbiamo bollato come
frigide perché non hanno riso alla
nostra battuta sconcia quante persone
della comunità lgbt abbiamo chiuso nello
stereotipo di troppo sensibile perché
non sono andate al cinema a vedere
l'ennesimo film che le usa come
espedienti comici
pensate a quante cose avremmo potuto
imparare se solo avessimo saputo prima
che le regole del gioco se il gioco non
riguardano e non le facciamo noi se
avessimo chiesto perché regola numero
due se vuoi giocare
devi seguire le regole la cosa che mi ha
fatto litigare di più nella mia vita è
la sequenza di più due più 4 che partono
ogni volta che si gioca a 1 il gioco di
carte ce l'avete presente
io gioco un più 2 e il mio avversario
deve pescare due carte invece no
lui gioca un più 2 a sua volta mi vuole
far pescare quattro carte ora non lo
puoi fare e non lo puoi fare perché in
ogni mazzo di carte di uno c'è un
foglietto con delle regole una delle
regole dice che se ti arriva un 32 tutte
ski due carte salti il turno
non esiste che cominciamo st catena di
sant'antonio di più 24 non lo puoi fare
e non voglio sentire ma io gioco così
perché loro le regole cosa lei fanno a
fare e poi anche ammesso di volerle
cambiare che non capisco perche perché
le regole le fa chi fa il gioco me lo
devi proporre per lima ma anche durante
tu dici di co2 e io dovrei anche venirti
dietro
fuori di metafora
se incontriamo una persona che fa parte
della comunità lgbt e usiamo il termine
[ __ ]
non possiamo aspettarci questa reagisca
bene perché [ __ ] è un insulto e di
base non va usato alcuni miei amici gay
si chiamano [ __ ] tra di loro
all'inizio la cosa mi confondeva è un
problema solo sulla uso io a parte che a
qualcuno da fastidio anche detto
all'interno della comunità ma comunque
un conto è se è un ragazzo gay a usare
il termine [ __ ] per depotenziarlo a tu
volevi insultarmi con quella parola ma
spreca il tuo tempo perché mi ci siamo
già da solo un altro è se io che non
faccio parte di quella comunità mi
arrogo il diritto di utilizzare quel
termine perché i miei amici gay lo fanno
o ai miei amici gay non dà fastidio
quando lo faccio io a casa mia con mio
papà o la regolati più due più 4 si
sommano ma non per questo se gioco con
qualcun'altro parto dal presupposto che
quella che è un eccezione più che essere
una nuova regola vada bene anche per lui
questo funziona anche a scala più grande
quando ad esempio si pensano dei
prodotti film canzoni per la comunità
lgbt e si fanno in un certo modo
ecco se la comunità lgbt ti dice che
quel modo non va bene non hai
alternative al cambiarlo o meglio
l'alternativa c'è ed è trincerarsi
dietro la giustificazione ormai abusata
del ma io l'ho fatto in buona fede
ecco la buona fede non funziona per una
semplice ragione la regola numero tre le
buone intenzioni non sono sufficienti
questa è forse la regola più difficile
da digerire perché se noi facciamo
qualcosa per un'altra persona
non accettiamo che qualcuno ci dica che
quella cosa non va bene o che
addirittura sia controproducente per la
persona per quello abbiamo fatta in
prima battuta e questo perché non c è
chiara una differenza che invece è
centrale per comprendere questo discorso
e cioè che intenzione ed effetto
prodotto non sempre coincidono
immaginiamoci la scena
incontriamo un'amica che non vediamo da
diverso tempo e le diciamo cavolo ma
come ti vedo bene sei dimagrito
tantissimo e lei ci risponde sì in
effetti perso parecchio peso perché è un
periodo in cui non sto particolarmente
bene anzi
speravo non si vedesse così tanto ayane
la nostra intenzione era quella di farle
un complimento perché dire sei dimagrita
e ancora considerato un complimento ci
vorrebbe un tetto al ca parte l'effetto
prodotto l'effetto prodotto è un
disastro
questo fa di noi dei mostri sadici che
amano far soffrire il prossimo ma certo
che no
ma il fatto che noi non volessimo farla
soffrire non è sufficiente tanto è vero
che lei sta soffrendo comunque certo noi
non lo sapevamo non è colpa nostra
però rimane una nostra responsabilità
perché siamo stati noi a dire quella
cosa anche se in buona fede come ne
usciamo
scusandoci dicendole che davvero non
volevamo farle riaffiorare emozioni
negative anzi se c'è qualcosa che
possiamo fare per stemperare un po la
tensione lo facciamo volentieri davvero
scusa la stessa cosa accade quando un
uomo nel tentativo di fare un
complimento a una donna finisce per
avere invece un atteggiamento molesto
giusto l'altro giorno guardavo i
messaggi sul mio instagram io ho trovato
uno di un ragazzo che mi diceva quanto
fosse bella quanto gli piacessero le mie
labbra carnose
ora io non conosco le intenzioni di
questo ragazzo
voglio essere ottimista pensare che
fosse il suo tentativo di farmi un
complimento
ciò nonostante io mi sono sentita molto
a disagio
era mattina avevo appena preso in mano
il telefono la prima cosa che ho dovuto
vedere
è stato questo messaggio da parte di uno
sconosciuto l'ho vissuta veramente come
un'invasione del mio privato ma perché
me lo stai dicendo perché pensi che mi
interessi se siete uomini
parlate con le donne della vostra vita
avranno tutte tutte una storia simile da
raccontarvi e moltissime di loro
utilizzeranno le stesse parole
mi sono sentita sporca incolpa
responsabile piena di vergogna capite
che le buone intenzioni non bastano se
una donna vi dice io mi sono sentita a
disagio il vostro ma io non volevo ha
senso solo se volete far sapere la
vostra intenzione non se pensate che
questo vi renda immuni alle critiche
eppure ogni volta che accadono scivoloni
del genere nel pubblico e nel privato la
tiritera è sempre la stessa
io l'ho fatto in buona fede quindi se tu
l'hai vissuta male problema è tuo che
sei troppo sensibile ecco no
se vuoi fare qualcosa di utile per
un'altra persona devi partire dal
presupposto che lei sappia meglio di te
come si possa fare devi fidarti di
quello che ti dice e se sbagli ed è
umano sbagliare
devi chiedere scusa e riprovare se ti
interessa giocare a questo gioco
sennò poi sempre propone un altro 1 in
cui le regole le fai solo tu le cambi a
tuo piacimento e se non vinci annulli la
partita
poi però devi trovare qualcuno disposto
a giocare con te buona fortuna
grazie
[Applauso]